in dresden begrüße ich ganz herzlich den
politikwissenschaftler professor werner
patient schon am nach dresden
guten abend herr patzelt hat sie die
heftige reaktion auf der straße nach
dieser bluttat überrascht sie hat mich
nicht sonderlich überrascht denn es gibt
in sachsen eine leidige tradition des
heftigen auch von überschäumenden
emotionen getragenen protestieren ist
verbreiten sich dann auch gerüchte sehr
schnell
und wenn die gerüchte darauf
hinauslaufen dass leute die aus dem
ausland schutz suchen nach deutschland
gekommen sind
in gewalttaten gegen auch deutsche sich
verwickeln lassen
dann kocht der volkszorn ob für recht
oder zu unrecht bleibt aufzuklären und
klarzustellen ist dann eben auf seiten
von politik und polizei
das ist so etwas wie selbstjustiz dass
es so etwas wie kollektive schuld dass
es so etwas wie angriffe auf alle die
anders aussehen als die länge schon im
lande lebenden nicht geben darf
blicken wir mal auf das phänomen was sie
hier zurecht angesprochen haben dass es
schon seit geraumer zeit so ist das ist
und bleibt es ein ostdeutsches
gegebenenfalls sogar ein sächsisches
problem hat sich das verstärkt
verringert wie sehen sie da die
veränderung viele in ostdeutschland
empfinden das für manches auf dem westen
ihnen auch gegen offenkundigen
widerstand aufgezwungen wurde vom
wirtschafts und gesellschaftssystem nach
der wiedervereinigung über westdeutsche
politik und kultur eliten bis hin zu
jener immigration die dann die großen
demonstrationen und die großen
wahlerfolge der afg im jahr 2016
auslöste
um das ganze ist dann eine sich selbst
bestätigen die kette von ereignissen
es taucht dann das hotfix
selbstzufriedene gefühl auf wir haben
immer schon recht gehabt und nun zeigt
die wirklichkeit dass es verkehrt war
uns einfach von verwischen
gefühlen beseelt darzustellen uns nicht
ernst zu nehmen und die probleme
schleifen zu lassen
und dieser prozess der sich selbst
bestärkt er hat in chemnitz wieder einen
neuen auslauf und höhepunkt gefunden und
zu befürchten ist dass das nicht das
letzte mal gewesen sein wird
zurzeit gehört aber auch dass bei
umfragen immer wieder bestätigt wird
dass es den deutschen besser geht als
jemals zuvor das land steht ja nicht nur
wirtschaftlich glänzend da die
arbeitsmarktdaten stimmen was läuft da
in der kommunikation falsch warum kommt
dies nicht bei den menschen an oder
nehmen sie es anders war das kommt bei
den leuten schon an und der zorn nähert
sich ja auch nicht aus persönlicher
wirtschaftlicher not sondern das
grundgefühl ist dass vieles das auch
durch große eigene anstrengungen mit
erreicht wurde jetzt gefährdet ist und
dass ein land in dem man gut und gerne
leben will und das immer schön und
besser zu machen lange zeit das
gemeinsame ziel gewesen ist nun einen
anderen akzent aufgeprägt bekommt einen
akzent in dem man sich unsicher fühlt in
dem uns sorge macht um die zukunft um
die weitere finanzierbarkeit der
sozialsysteme
es ist also kurzum gesagt nicht
unzufriedenheit mit der gegenwart
sondern sorge um die zukunft und ärger
über all jene denen band für recht oder
zu unrecht zu schreibt die zukunft
dieses landes zu riskieren
und erst wenn man diesen größeren
verursachung zusammenhang mit auf dem
schirm hat wird man begreifen dass
zurechtweisungen warnungen einfach nicht
ausreichen um diese dynamik diese
entsetzliche dynamik in den kommenden
monaten und jahren in den griff zu
bekommen
haben sie den eindruck dass da überhaupt
noch was zu retten ist der zug nicht
eigentlich fast schon ein stück weit
abgefahren weil die die jetzt
demonstrieren da hat man ja nicht den
eindruck dass man die je wieder zurück
konnten
ich bin im lauf der jahre und monate
immer skeptischer geworden
am anfang hätte man durch demonstratives
angehen und lösen von problemen den
einen oder anderen vor emotionalen
intellektuellen und moralischen irrwegen
wohl bewahren können
aber inzwischen haben so viele diesen
gemeinwesen trotzig innerlich gekündigt
sind viele so auf der erregung spuren
von der von dem eindruck nach gerade
beseelt man müsse es immer wieder durch
demonstrationen zeigen dass das eigene
land sei dass man sich dies und jenes
nicht gefallen ließ dass ich wirklich
allmählich fürchte dass hier eine
bewegung in gang gesetzt worden ist die
sich jetzt nur noch schwer wenn
überhaupt aufhalten lässt prozent sie
haben die parteien gehört und auch den
regierungssprecher insbesondere vorne
auch die alternative für deutschland die
sich von der gewalt auf der straße
distanziert wohl gleich aber in einigen
bereichen verständnis für die wut der
bürger äußert inwieweit ist das wasser
auf die mühlen derer die ein problem mit
migration und integration haben
zunächst einmal ist es gut dass alle
politischen parteien die sich geäußert
haben gewalttätigkeit selbstjustiz und
alles was furchtbar hässlich und in
romanen in chemnitz gewesen ist scharf
verurteilen
es fällt aber schon auf was beschwiegen
wird nämlich beschwiegen wird eine
mögliche antwort auf die frage ob es
nicht anschluss probleme unserer
migrations und integrationspolitik gibt
die eben immer wieder in solchen und
anderen szenen in den kommenden jahren
und jahrzehnten aufbrechen werden so
dass die praktische frage lautet wie
verbessern wir die integration von für
uns gekommenen in unserer gesellschaft
wie schaffen wir es dass jenes erreichte
niveau an zivilität dessen wir uns
jahrzehntelang römern kommt dann dass
dieses video zur alltagspraktischen
selbstverständlichkeit wird und dass es
weder auf der straße zu
messerstechereien noch zu jagdszenen wie
in chemnitz kommt wie kommen wir dorthin
das wäre das thema das es zu erörtern
gilt und dass auf dem weg dorthin eine
nicht behandlung dieses themas keine
plausiblen antworten auf diese fragen
wasser auf die mühlen von der
rechtspopulisten sind ja da steht er nun
völlig außer zweifel
offensichtlich hat die politik politik
beschäftigt sich ja nun schon etwas
länger mit der frage ist es ja nicht das
erste mal dass darüber diskutiert wird
ob migration und integration in diesem
land schief gelaufen ist es scheint kein
allheilmittel zu geben wo sehen sie
gerade in sachsen beispielsweise die
defizite
die defizite sind die dass man den
leuten einfach gesagt hat erstens es
gibt migration die flüchtlinge sind da
dagegen kann man nichts tun man muss
einfach unterbringen und dass man
zweitens den leuten gesagt hat es wird
auch gar nicht schlimm werden denn jene
die kommen sind gut ausgebildet sie
bereichern unseren arbeitsmarkt zu
machen unsere gesellschaft einfach bunt
und schön
und da fühlten sich viele leute
sozusagen im zweifel ob das alles denn
wirklich so wäre und sie fühlen sich
jetzt von der politik getäuscht um
schlimmere wörter zu vermeiden das ganze
hat zu weiteren spaltung unserer
gesellschaft zu dieser großen auch
emotionalen polarisierung beigetragen in
der ein vernünftiger diskurs über so
wichtige themen wie migration und
integration immer schwieriger wird und
das ist eine lage welche die leute in
sachsen insbesondere deswegen besonders
aufregt soll von hier aus sozusagen die
ersten warnsignale ergangen sind dass
man mit einem lasso fair und der aussage
es wird schon alles gut eben eine so
gigantische folgenreiche politik besser
nicht betreiben sollte ich danke ihnen
herzlich für ihre deutlichen worte
professor werner patzelt nach dresden